what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
she-hulk episode three john how's it
going i am very good how are you sir i'm
doing good it feels better without coy
being here no it's better without coin
so crowded when he's here the reason
koi's not on the video dave we all went
to the premiere of she-hulk we did not
know that they would be playing episode
three a lot will attest they saw john
and i booed out of that theater once
episode three started play haven't seen
a second of it coy did no such thing
shame on you koi
shame you want to be part of the reject
nation you got to learn to not
experience stuff with a crowd take this
and watch it in my home yeah you guys
anyway guys leave a like that would be
very much appreciated as always full
interaction watch as long as we sync up
with the time code with your own copy
before she hooked our super sexy rejects
at our patreon page what i really wanted
to talk about today is today's sponsor
someone who i've been wanting to work
with for so long because you guys might
see me taking a lot of sips out of
blender bottles here on the channel it's
either a shake or it's a product that i
consume literally every single day
you'll know that in my kitchen got a
crap ton of this g-fuel really does help
me stay focused it helps me stay
energized especially when you have to be
on camera so often this is the most
natural thing we could have possibly
partnered up with considering that i've
already been taking their products for
so long now use our affiliate code in
the description box reject nation if you
want to pick yourself up some g-fuel
today seriously g phil thank you for
finally working with me dang it
i was forced
to leave my cell but i returned
of my own free will who forced you that
is true sorcerer supreme of the mystic
arts and his name is
wong
he's either
a sorcerer who lives in new york what a
librarian you know if blonsky's telling
the truth this guy busted him out of his
prison cell and probably ruined my
entire case
i know you can't wait to see long i get
it
like you don't think this is one of
those cameo every week type of shows
that's not
well except bruce
and blonsky
and wong
just remember whose show this actually
is
daredevil show there's daredevil
get to it the statuesque green lawyer
has been plagued by public backlash with
many questioning her qualifications
of course
the big green
now we have a me too movement this would
never happen in real life we have too
much history for me to be comfortable
with her on the case i would love to
know what this is about and not work on
it
you wanted to see me ah yes malory book
is also in the superhuman lottery yeah
finally meeting malory it looks cool
yeah i'll take him
well
our friend
i identify with this guy he's been
defrauded by an ex-girlfriend and wants
to file a suit against her to get his
money back florida bali for a photo
shoot paid off for volkswagen passat
subscribers why the superhuman law
division the girlfriend in question is a
shape-shifting light elf from new asgard
oh nice i thought i was dating megan the
stallion sorry you thought you were
dating megan the stalin a multiple
grammy award winner mega star megan the
sound what part of shape shifter did you
not get
you thought she drove up a sun
oh snap about time i received your
message my man i extracted him from the
prison
against his own wishes because i
required a worthy opponent as part of my
training to become sorcerer supreme and
as sorcerers okay my insist that he not
be punished for my actions
uh again
what you can do to help is show up at
the hearing and explain everything very
well we'll reserve sorcery for strategy
b don't tap your nose
[Laughter]
how much money and cash and gifts did
you spend on the megan the stallion
imposter
oh man
a hundred
two hundred two hundred thousand i am
not a fool
i'm gonna start building your case and i
will be in touch mr mukowski
all right paper covers rock oh i've been
in that situation too many times
no way
i'm going to drop the case wait wait
just now what the truth is
but at some point in time you got to
take personal responsibility i have to
say this is unexpected well it's just
money after all and now i have a
i got a story to tell
write a
oh
i see security yep
yep get the she-hulk
to women in the workplace it's my kick
baby
oh no
be a warning
i
don't
you guys know me
it's okay you're one of the good ones
buddy
is that her
she-hulk can we get a word is it true
you were rejected by the avengers
oh walters also known as she-hulk
rumored to have been rejected by the
avengers oh my god fake news are you
ready for this
are you hanging on the edge of your seat
is women uh are those your soulmates oh
yeah definitely the thunderbolts let's
start by saying that i feel
great remorse
great shame
so to answer your question yes i feel i
have been rehabilitated
i have changed emotionally physically
metaphysically spiritually karmically
cosmically interdimensional etc
mr blonsky does own a plot of land on
which he plans to work and reside he's
going into farming no actually he plans
to open a meditation retreat on the
property so which is very
you know and
they are my better
eights
love you it's like a little mini
midsummer going on right there he's
gonna be in a bear costume by the end of
the episode he saved me from a bad
marriage that's a call let it flow now
the library is more than just a quiet
place to shoot someone
[Laughter]
is that all
because there's still the matter of mr
blonsky's escape
god damn it wong a witness will explain
if he ever decides to show up
my apologies miss walter's swimming meal
ah finally
ah it's cool reflection or glasses yeah
she has diplomatic immunity she may have
diplomatic immunity in new asgard but we
are not in new ascot excuse me your
honor but asgard is not a place
my client was defrauded of 175 000 by a
scam artist
he deserves compensation for the
financial and emotional trauma that he
is suffering my client and mr bukowski
were in a consensual relationship and
engaged in role play oh great no
kinky i find it hard to believe that mr
pakowski could be fooled so easily and
the illness is on you to prove that mr
poogley z that being said i'll allow
this to go to trial so miss runa your
motion to dismiss is denied let's get
megan this style unit here
cameo every week
he's excited because he's she
impersonating a judge is illegal get
down from there
[Applause]
this is very good for us
[Laughter]
she just helped prove their case
i offered them asylum at the camotage
just truly lovely this time of the year
but he was quite adamant he'd be
returned to serve out his sentence
and repay his debt to society
thank you
well that may be true of emil blonsky
but
when blonsky uncontrollably becomes
abomination isn't he a raging monster
out for blood
excuse me
if i could just put your minds at ease
oh no absolutely oh golly let's do it
[Applause]
everyone calm down wait
as you can see
i'm in full control
that's enough change back now
[Applause]
[Music]
calm down you can't be naked it's the
first time any of the prison people have
seen him that way mr blonsky
could have broken free but has chosen
to remain in his cell she actually makes
a good point man let's get this man some
clothes
oh yeah and as for mr wong just one
the sorcerer's supreme master of
domestic arts leader and former
librarian of common taj yeah
breaker of chains mother of dragons how
do you plan to take gwanski down when he
rampages again creator responder claims
that you're one of lost these rumored
soul mates is there any truth to the
rumors you got your powers from a mafia
had gone wrong
ah
nice easter egg dennis bukowski oh yeah
no you're gonna need that connecting the
a b story nice
oh i killed him in my head several times
the man is almost terminally deluded i'd
call him gross yeah
hey would you be willing to say that
under oath
i oh [ __ ] we worked regularly on cases
together so i've
spent a lot of time with mr bukowski did
he ever share his personal life with you
specifically his dating life yes he
would uh prolifically and unprompt
[Laughter]
that's right brah
dennis bukowski is an almost
pathologically entitled man he would
absolutely believe that he's dating the
real megan the stallion because he is
truly that delusional
[Laughter]
a-plus testimony
i award full damages to dennis bukowski
in the amount of 175
000
wow
we also sentenced the defendant to 60
days
for impersonating a judge
no no no no no no no
that's right oh [ __ ]
do you guys think i have a shot with the
real megan to style you should i go back
no
yes you should now let's get cardi b in
the next episode
and nicki minaj and lizzo
after reviewing his record we hereby
grant mr blonsky's release on parole
effective immediately thunderbolts
mr blonsky is prohibited from turning
into abomination indefinitely
she is ordered to wear an inhibitor in
perpetuity any violation of this
condition will result in his immediate
return to prison understood stakes for
the thunderbolts
i i don't want to read any more stories
about either of us you might want to
reconsider that i mean they're going to
write a story about you one way or the
other you know
better to be part of it really
[Music]
oh
the abomination is now a free man and
here with us in the studio the lawyer
responsible for his release she-hulk
yeah my name's jennifer walters not
she-hulk and uh my client's name is emil
blonsky not the abomination
got it
i just felt all the
ratings dip how did you come up with the
name she-hulk oh
funny story i didn't journalism when we
come back she-hulk shares her diet and
exercise sequence i'm sorry what
be a hulk
i got it
oh [ __ ] the wrecking crew oh wait
if you're gonna strut around
showing off your powers you better be
able to back it up when do i ever strut
around and show off my powers
you're a woman and you have them did you
guys rob an asgardian construction
worker
yeah
yeah
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
okay bad idea bad idea once you turned
into she-hulk i couldn't pierce that
nasty green skin damn it mom's gonna be
mad
boss thunderbolt boss
woke up this morning
nice
dang i wonder who the boss is
kingpin
everyone's kingpin yep kingpin
yeah daredevil's coming king king's
gonna follow and then they're gonna be
an echo
release transport
goodbye ladies
see you soon
hi there's my new favorite client
just
just your signature there
and initials up here
she's a superhuman
she twerk
way more fun than my last lawyer i will
kill for you megan you still
damn
all right let's chit chat
all right johnny the new koi take it
away okay guys well comics let's talk
about the origins of all these different
characters that i recognized throughout
the show
and uh i'm not getting the body language
now
listen guys coy i don't have enough arm
mass to
all right so
you're going to be in your face i'm
going to look at you intensely and i got
to go wide-eyed when i'm talking about
things from time to time
that was not bad i thought he was here
for a second there
and then i'm going to share my own views
about woke politics
which is good which which i'm glad he
does i'm glad he's willing to do that
unlike us who must chill and keep
everyone happy yeah i hate women but i
love women i love and hate women
and dichotomy men's rights need to be
upheld but also women's rights earth or
should be a thing all right
well yeah and like in this show like how
it doesn't give an f word at all
especially when it went through the
comments
flat out it's like they they knew well
in advance the exact response the show
was gonna get yep it's not like they
reworked it or i mean it's marvel they
could have they could have redone it
last week if they wanted to all the
things that they could have done quick i
suppose it is that they could have seen
the trailer responses been like throw
this in the visual effects during that
montage
some poor vfx artists like oh my god
what what do you need oh just some
comments all right okay that's easy yeah
yeah but when they are going through the
comments they do have all those remarks
um about you know like i'm sick and
tired of everyone becoming a female
superhero who asked for this fake jolly
green giant looking character or
whatever what do we have to do to get
she-hulk canceled so i i feel like they
they are going after exactly everything
i love that i just i i love it because
they knew exactly what would happen with
this show and they're deciding to just
directly attack it head on making the
self-awareness making them making the
metaness and the self-awareness that
much more prevalent in front of the
audience's faces
so it seems
no i
i agree coy yeah get a quick incident
before i take it
yeah no i i think they they've done
really nicely and and i think it over
the course of these three years
listening from my turn to get it it has
listening
to talk yeah
intensely waiting for my turn talk and
right back to you coy uh no i think
they've done nicely over the three
episodes we've seen so far to show that
yeah they know exactly what world we are
living in and they know exactly what the
response is gonna be and for those
people they know that those people are
probably going to write them off from
the get-go so yeah to have this kind of
fun and to and to
you know i i don't believe that these
were added in just last week i think
they probably yeah we do they know the
time and place in which we live
and it is very well attuned to and
suited to that and if it's riling you up
then you know you're probably who
they're talking about where would you
rank this episode out of the three john
uh i would saw a b b plus b b plus
yeah sure yeah uh yeah you know i i i'd
say maybe not quite as high as episode
two uh but then again i don't know
there's things that like you know wong
ultimate like automatically bonus points
love wong loved his involvement in the
episode the megan the stallion thing on
the other hand i thought was funny
cheeky but it's like such a prevalent
here and now
pop culture reference that i'm like okay
like i'm not annoyed or or begrudging of
this but also it is like
okay
our culture that we live in and then you
know it's fine uh but i thought it was
funny beyond that like as distracting as
the repetition constantly of the name
megan the stallion kind of became to me
i thought what they made out of that was
pretty funny and i liked the
intersecting cases where jen has to go
testify on behalf of this guy she hates
and just tell the truth about it yeah
yeah um yeah i liked it a lot i mean i
would say that you know
it's
the ranking wouldn't be that uh you know
sharp because i mean i've enjoyed these
three pretty much all in tandem so in
some ways this might be my favorite one
yet um but i guess episode two just
didn't have that like distraction factor
for me but where would you uh where
would you put it where would i put it
yeah
well
let me think about that
i mean if i were to rank this episode
you know it'd be like solid seven eight
out of ten you know if i were to put it
within the marvel pantheon of the marvel
shows i'd probably put it right in
between wonder vision and loki but a
little bit above hawkeye
yeah
easily in my top 19.
out of all 47 episodes that have come
out on the marvel disney plus app i
would put this at number 26. yeah
maybe 25 but i'm pretty confident in 26.
just off the top of my head
my whole video this video is just for
for the koi stands yes
you're either going to be really upset
or really in love with this one
it's good it's subtle coy impressions
yeah
for the podcast listeners
i'll describe it to you greg's leaning
forward he's got both hands out he's got
a big wide-eyed expression on his face
he's like really excited yeah he's got
that sort of good boyish good-natured
thing coy has my head's going to explode
with comics and comic references
yeah yeah yeah
that's good you're like a koi to me
i i believe it
i believe anyway
uh
yeah i i i don't care rank it uh it's
it really felt like a
where i felt like the first and second
episode and maybe i just needed like two
more minutes before
making the statement
where i felt like the first and second
episode really feel like a complete
episode this feels like a setup episode
even though there are some definitive
things that happen here emil blonsky
being let out of arkham asylum yeah
finally being able to join batman's
rogue galleries finally dude finally go
on the street work for the penguin yeah
that's right that's right
and uh you know he'll run into the joker
at some point you know maybe maybe he'll
freak out maybe he'll get fear toxin and
then he'll abominate out again and then
get back into trouble
i wish the courtroom scenes if there's
one thing i do kind of crave from it a
little bit is that i wish the courtroom
scenes had a little bit more
like genuine
spunk to it some actual vitality you
know like a feeling of i'm not looking
for you know goddamn law order or
something like that in nature you know
i'm not looking for the most intense
thing in the world but it does just kind
of feel like
like the quick outline rushing through
to to get
to the thing to get to the conclusion of
the trial you know yeah and i wish there
was a little bit more meat to chew on
within some of the trials
because we were cutting around a two
and they were just happening in such a
whiplash pace
not that it was wasn't like necessarily
wasn't upset when i was sometimes you
say something and it sounds like oh i
[ __ ] hate it but that's that's not
the case it really all it was is when i
look back on it that's what i was hoping
that's what i would want more of
because it's she-hulk it's an attorney
it's called attorney at law so i'd want
like some more compelling courtroom
scenes or something that just just says
resonate in that department
yet it doesn't really do that it's just
more fun
and it's kind of like sometimes feels a
little throw away that's what
daredevil's going to bring this is the
person who always watched daredevil and
was like i like the courtroom stuff too
let's get more courtroom stuff
like i do
i do agree i mean i enjoyed the bits and
pieces in the courtroom we get i'm
excited to see the eventual legal eagle
breakdowns of these episodes but yeah i
mean i i enjoy a good legal like when
you have a legal legal not do the
breakdowns of this one no
dealing with superhero law division
but you can tell like there was one
hearing that had no jury and that's
probably like a certain kind of hearing
where like you know you don't need a
jury it's like it's a you know it's like
things like that legal realism man
i mean he's done like cartoons and stuff
if i were to rank this courtroom case
out of all the marvel courtroom cases
that we've seen so far i put it number
13 out of daredevil season 2 when
defending the punisher
but not as good as defending coolio
oh yeah
that's number one
leaning over to talk to you
yeah
all the way over and all the way profile
it's good i i but yeah like when when a
show
this is the most mad cap review in a
show who can do that and reach that
point where you are very much sort of
just like caught up in the breathless
breathlessness of a lawyer's argument
that is a really special place that i
think a lot of law shows and films have
gone to that i would like to see this
show get to because yes
i want the show to meet jen halfway on
that promise from the first episode
where she's like legal show
lawyer show and yeah like like all the
mcu context is really fun but yeah like
i would love to
see this
blossom into something that does have
like an actual legal show heft about it
yeah because
i don't know there's something about the
introduction of the wrecking crew that
did not excite me
in fact it it felt
like oh i was kind of liking what the
show is without you know we need a big
baddie i don't know why i was really i
was more into what the show is already
doing
versus trying to establish like oh yeah
yeah we're uh because it's so it's
already
like well aware it's a marvel show it
it's definitely it's like most
definitely a marvel show i'm not gonna
sit here and be like i like that it
wasn't being a marvel when it was more
than a marvel show absolutely
yet the whole thing with having a a
titular villain you got to eventually
punch
that was something i
was not even really thinking about
whatsoever i've been more invested in
this
strange
having to work via
publicity social media being
a uh trying to balance work life with
now being thrusted into the superhero
position this new law division like all
those things i'm like that's the that's
the juicy stuff to me yeah but then
wrecking crew shows up and we want to
take her her um
her blood so we can replicate it you
know i know you think it's thunderbolt
ross or titanic i personally think it's
dr doom this is going to tie into
adventure secret wars uh
here's how she-hulk is setting up the
entirety of avengers secret wars
uh no i i would agree with you on that
because yeah it's like part of the charm
has been like oh cool they're really
committed to episodic sitcom
as you know part of the mcu and and her
crossing paths with all these heroes and
their uh and villains and and their
relation to the law
is like enough so yeah i feel like it
starts to feel like oh here's the
element and hey maybe they'll do
something cool different with it but
here's the element that is the most akin
to everything i've seen before and what
i like about the show is it's
kind of twisting and playing with and
being different from a lot of the stuff
i've seen before in the mcu so yeah now
it's like oh big bad needs the blood
you know
is there going to be ultimately like a
big punch out battle at the end is it
that kind of show i hope so yes i wish
it was just that i hope it's just punch
punch punch just she-hulk just like that
great fight scene they had with the
wrecking crew well that's the thing too
it's like with these little effects with
the fights thus far i've been like i
like the
the concept of these fights and i like
like the idea of the choreography but
but yeah like the fights themselves are
a bit like these are mostly just in
editing yeah they're not like oh damn
the action is crazy which i'm not asking
for it to be really it's one of those
things where it's like if you're going
to do it i guess you got to kind of make
it crazy
uh john the action looked [ __ ] weird
it looked a bit weird and so
so did the titania bit in the first
episode but that felt at least
intentional like it had a bit of that
luck my name titania i'm here and i'm
gonna do a video wrestling
exploitation seventies vibe sure
it felt intentional we're here when she
punches it was like
yeah
someone's going to defend the [ __ ] out
of it go ahead um
yeah it doesn't matter no it's the way
shoe mushy she-hulk doesn't need to
exert that much my top 10 fights in the
mcu all she-hulk episode 3.
yeah
not as good as we try to do your koi
impression
you know acting like you were doing like
a half rock impression by aaron
alexander my top ten
my top ten fights in the mcu
this is gonna change the hierarchy of
fights
yeah michael that's how i see koi he's
just so jacked yeah you're basically the
rock now you're way bigger than i am and
you're not even as tall as me
um cinema okay
and so yeah i like the uh
i mean it's not a big to me all that
[ __ ] is the stuff i don't care about
like the action i don't care about
it doesn't bug me that much yet because
i'm not really here for that so much
i guess i was more also drawn to the
character hurdle she had to go through
in the second episode
whereas here
there was so much being kind of
thrown in
you know you got wong then you got
bukowski's case and then you got the the
runa character
which was all elements i i i enjoyed
like i enjoyed everything that was here
this was a very enjoyable episode
but with the the cliffhanger of last
week's episode
i thought that cliffhanger was more
exciting than what we actually got yeah
because then wong shows up and and like
they tease you that he might not show
for the actual trial but like pretty
much everything goes according to plan
and when he shows up it's like okay as
long as he testifies this it's gonna be
fine
yeah yeah there was no real like i
thought it was like oh [ __ ] that's crazy
yeah and then it was oh okay oh all
right
yeah unless there's something else you
know unless wong is being entirely
truthful or whatever but yeah and it's
funny because i liked the interplay of
the two cases and the and it's like i
liked this episode and what they did
with it i also feel like there's a
different version where you could have
done these as kind of two separate
episodes or two separate cases or you
could have done one where jen isn't in
the courtroom or isn't doing you know
isn't arguing the law so much and then
we're you know in with pug and them in
the actual you know case for um you know
for bukowski but even so i mean i
thought that was a fun way to like
further expound upon pug's character and
to get to like meet him a little bit
more
so
yeah it's like it's it's it's weird it's
like i don't
begrudge it for not going differently
but i can see how it could go
differently and it is a sort of
interesting thing i feel like we'll get
a better idea the more episodes we get
as to how kind of they want to tailor
the suspense expectations because it's
you know it's caught in this place where
it needs to be fun and amusing and it
needs to riff on legal stuff but it also
needs i think to have
or or seems to want to have some kind of
big you know intriguing quality of like
oh man you know
how's yeah i don't know like what
i'm curious about how they'll maintain
and they'll continue to grow the stakes
aside from whatever you know season arc
they need her blood situation that aside
i'm curious to see how they'll maintain
stakes like that because yeah when this
one ends you're like okay
that's so that's wrapped up and then
next week we'll have something new to
focus on well i thought was like
surprisingly kind of cool and topical
um
is uh
like i'm in my own subconscious
association way
who's with
the presenter at the vmas johnny depp um
the
moon man
with johnny depp and uh the who was it
what was his attorney's name oh golly
the the the young woman
yeah the main one
yeah i couldn't tell you but how she was
like becoming really popular and then
doing interviews and becoming like a
celebrity herself yeah for representing
um johnny depp
who was an abomination in the streets
just terrorizing all the harlem johnny
yeah
and he's out there writing haikus uh
yeah and stealing them from other
people's songs i guess
weird jointed up stories lately
no when yeah when uh when that was
happening that's kind of what i was
liking it to so it seems like a lot of
what happened in this episode is also
setting up
it seemed like a major setup for what's
to come more than anything else because
you have jen
who is now this popular
lawyer
and getting this stardom that she didn't
ask for she wants to be viewed if i have
kind of it's like she has to be she
wants to be viewed as just her own
identity and not be shown as she-hulk
but she's being forced to go on the news
as she-hulk because she's going to be
representing her firm she has to be in
she-hulk form yeah
which is kind of like up and down for me
like okay that's right because of the
dodc when representing uh she that they
did establish in the last episode that
she cannot be in power form that's right
that the guard did tell her that okay
wipe that thought even though i didn't
even declare it out loud
i'm wiping it off the table right now
not a plot hole it's not a plot hole
yeah yeah yeah they established it in
the second episode when she was going to
the hannibal lecter visit
so yeah they they uh it's just she has
to go show up and form her own identity
and so i like that struggle i like the
struggle that she's having with
like something that feels simple and
you know and i i guess i'm trying to get
more into
characters have goals and i want to go
more into the why behind the goals you
know what i mean like that's where you
lack that's how you create that's really
how you create stakes especially if it's
not a life or death situation yeah it's
you got to go into why what does it mean
the goal means so much to them
versus
and and what the what the
what can be lost
for not achieving it for what that does
to the person you know yeah this episode
doesn't do as much personally and then
they also have the setup with the person
trying to take the blood how that ends
and now now she's got a target on her
back like her whole life has really
changed after all this
she's achieved becoming a successful
lawyer prolific one but it's not in the
way at all how she had dreamed of the
entire time she has pursued it so
there's a lot in the writing that i'm
definitely on board with and there's a
there's so much here happening that i'm
really enjoying like it's it's very very
enjoyable yeah uh i i i can't help
though when the episode ended being like
there's just a little bit more
there's just a little bit more off that
i'm kind of craving yeah something there
just bring it out and just wring it out
i would like that yeah call me some kind
of woke soy boy cuck but but i do
find that stuff the most intriguing is
that personal struggle of like she goes
on the news to try and you know to take
control of the narrative and they're
asking her all these fluffy questions
and now yeah she's becoming a target for
her blood and everybody has various
reasons not to take her seriously and to
be upset you know by her very position
and those things i think are interesting
yeah and i and yeah whenever they do
turn to that i'm like i would i could do
with more dramatic exploration of this
too i like the
rooney like i thought there was a
a beat that they could have hit with the
runa character
that i thought could have had like some
kind of crazy consequences
because i was about i was preparing
myself to feel really bad for her
even though she's doing a lot of these
what are essentially just glorified
pranks right yeah
like just very heightened
albeit illegal
pranks that she's doing
when i thought that we're going to
sentence her to like [ __ ] like years
in prison yeah oh no
and i thought there might have been like
a serious damage to like oh because i
helped i thought there was something
kind of cool that they could have
brought out again i know this is
something where i am putting my own
desire into something that is not what
they are doing
uh i'm gonna say it anyway
is i thought it would have been more
interesting personally if
it was that she does testify against
bukowski you get the irony that by her
getting to vent her her truths about her
opinion about bukowski that that allows
him to win his case the uh the ironic
sense of winning yet someone this runa
character suffers greatly
at that and i thought that would have
been a cool way to
kind of amplify the superhero law
division part as well you know
um as maybe wanting to now defend this
per i don't know if there would be a
conflict of personal interest or
whatever whatever it's a marvel show
about something everyone's signed the
way yeah
like they make it work so yeah i thought
there was like more interesting things
they could have done and and and with
and wong showing up is fun we know he's
going to show up again some more uh so
that's gonna be the new part but it also
seemed like they were yeah i think a lot
of this was set up for wong as well
and you know thunderbolts
and uh doom doctor
forcing atlantis to attack wakanda yeah
yeah there's i got a lot of those notes
in this got a lot of that
got a lot of that megan these stallion's
going to play a big part in that war
yeah
it's fun it's light
and at the end of the day that's what a
lot of people just kind of want too
honestly
that's what a lot of people are just
kind of liking and and wanting and uh
for me even like some of my favorite
[ __ ] to watch on my own time is that
yeah just generally speaking you know
i'm on like season 14 if it's always
sunny in philadelphia right now so i'd
like to just watch fun [ __ ]
so yeah i totally get and of course like
the the optics
around someone what
a regular viewer might experience
versus people who do videos
who are like they're doing a video we
need substance because we got to talk
about some [ __ ]
you know uh they i think we would
probably crave just a little bit more
just because by by virtue of what we do
versus what an average audience member
is like it was fun yeah yeah i mean
overall i'm quite pleased and very much
enjoying what's happening because too
it's a nice breath of fresh air for the
mcu and i love yeah the the humorousness
i think the fourth wall breaks are
really fun and well timed and not overly
obnoxiously used and yeah like there is
just a fun novelty of watching these
different colorful characters collide
and even here like it was nice to at
least zoom back in on our main ensemble
even though it is like a there are a lot
of people appearing i love pug pug is
great i think uh
i think he's great um
very charming it's funny when he came
out as the
when bruno was impersonating him that
was more like the adrian chase from
arrow the kind of
smuggish
cocky version uh and i was like no he
does know how to play that that
character yeah yeah really well and so i
really enjoyed uh i really enjoy his
performance a lot i think he brings
something uh refreshing totally i think
the man is the best part of this female
driven show is what i'm trying to tell
everyone right now favorite characters i
would say uh pug bruce wong
buckowski definitely very layer deep
character
uh and then you know maybe maybe nikki
and jen what would make this show brave
is if they put them more front and
center and they put jen in the backseat
a little bit yeah right
i'm just saying yeah i'm just saying
yeah the same way they they put all the
men in the back and they put all the
women in the front of all the other
male-led ones generally yeah yeah
they're woke and they're trying to
destroy our marvels uh what are you
gonna do
anyway
um yep they mentioned gideon wilson cool
yeah world war hulk
easter egg it's gonna show how she got
shot cool yeah the mob off yeah there
you go that was
[Music]
there's this right we're pointing out
the easter egg mallory book oh hey
that's right one day i mean they become
enemies and then then they become
friends there's an up-and-down
relationship with them you got a little
little news crawl about titania hoping
to win a case mr eggs easter eggs bruh
drags easter
he is risen
he's risen i just got it
clever yeah man coming to the mcu soon
enough and we got some twerking we got
twerking two in the post-credits scene
it's always what i wanted
i i missed the days with everything in
marvel it wasn't a big
that's what they should do is they
should take their half-hour comedy show
and make it crushingly serious it's
almost as if when the avengers assembled
it wasn't the funniest one leading up to
that point
it's not
it's almost as if we never applauded
those movies we're bringing in a fresh
sense of meta-ironic humor
[Laughter]
yeah it's just all jokes now man it's
all yucking it up with the mcu
the cube don't like comics have never
been funny and they've never been aimed
at the youth
or should they nor should they these are
these are
likes much like star wars these are for
adults did we shout everyone on our
patreon i'm pretty sure we did we should
we could shout out some of the rest of
of our of our good supporters already
august september 1st man oh then we've
already done it
all right let's shut them all up zachary
i'm going to chow down on irfan
chowdhury takish
lucky ashante sohate rhymin with ian
simon songhai clover dover glow over too
soon jacob neptune new metal bra run
from the cops fan pops sing sing sing
with an alan ling skirting by logan
burton what kira 365 days a year don't
resign ericans39
you move me cousy cousy bear in the
garage insert rhyme with garage
nick x send me a slick text juan
longoria
i'm gonna take you to bolivia gail reads
braille ferguson muhammad al-shar ronnie
uh
i wanna take you to a burger at tommy's
jaron james wanner
cliff rodriguez we in the business
master turnstiles john the goat nothing
wrong with goats
olivia del guy ring that bell from on
high
get a steam punk looking lock andy funk
lorenzo baxter survive in the slasher
movie you're the final girl let hell
reign as we become differently sane
paying my bills with marco ton stills my
voice is feeling hoarse as i'm writing
lauren american horror i shouldn't make
that joke
[Laughter]
simply faded but never jaded joanna
saint louis
rogue creed joanna saint luiso wait a
minute
sj94
that's a high score pop tart and justin
martin rosie beatty you're a sexy lady
colin
where are you calling from colin
philip j smith jr
ah it's
lunar time
yep you weirdo
you're the stuff of myths jen smith
melanie blanc
cronk from emperor's new groove matt
beer
is is super frothy and and refreshing
and it won't fill you up tg truck us
oh goddamn
uh
uh hibiscus
it was good really brought it home there
thanks guys for being here love you all
all of you god equally
you're all of the she-hulk
for our hearts jesus christ
[Music]